[Music]
like many heroes of Greek myths the
philosopher hipa sious was rumored to
have been mortally punished by the gods
but what was his crime did he murder
guests or disrupt a sacred ritual no
HIPPA sis's transgression was a
mathematical proof the discovery of
irrational numbers hip assist belonged
to a group called the Pythagorean
mathematicians who had a religious
reverence for numbers their dictum of
all is number suggested that numbers
were the building blocks of the universe
and part of this belief was that
everything from cosmology and
metaphysics to music and morals followed
eternal rules describable as ratios of
numbers thus any number could be written
as such a ratio 5 as 5 over 1 0.5 as 1
over 2 and so on even an infinitely
extending decimal like this could be
expressed exactly as 34 over 45 all of
these are what we now call rational
numbers but HIPAA suspend that violated
this harmonious rule one that was not
supposed to exist the problem began with
a simple shape a square with each side
measuring one unit according to
Pythagoras theorem the diagonal length
would be square root of 2 but try as he
might HIPAA says cannot express this as
a ratio of two integers and instead of
giving up he decided to prove it
couldn't be done
HIPPA sustained by assuming that the
Pythagorean worldview was true that root
2 could be expressed as a ratio of two
integers he labeled these hypothetical
integers P and Q assuming the ratio was
reduced to its simplest form P and Q
could not have any common factors to
prove that root 2 was not rational
hippest had to prove that P over Q
cannot exist so he multiplied both sides
of the equation by Q and squared both
sides which gave him this equation
multiplying any number by two results in
an even number
so p-squared had to be even that
couldn't be true if P was odd because an
odd number times itself is always odd so
P was even as well
thus P could be expressed as two times a
where a is an integer substituting this
into the equation and simplifying gave Q
squared equals two times a squared once
again two times any number produces an
even number so Q squared must have been
even and Q must have been even as well
making both P and Q even but if that was
true then they had a common factor of
two which contradicted the initial
statement and that's how HIPAA says
concluded that no such ratio exists
that's called a proof by contradiction
and according to the legend the gods did
not appreciate being contradicted
interestingly even though we can't
express irrational numbers as ratios of
integers it is possible to precisely
plot some of them on the number line
take root two all we need to do is form
a right triangle with two sides each
measuring one unit the hypotenuse has a
length of root 2 which can be extended
along the line we can then form another
right triangle with a base of that
length and a 1 unit height and its
hypotenuse would equal root 3 which can
be extended along the line as well the
key here is that decimals and ratios are
only ways to express numbers root 2
simply is the hypotenuse of a right
triangle with sides of a length 1
similarly the famous irrational number
pi is always equal to exactly what it
represents the ratio of a circles
circumference to its diameter
approximations like 22 over 7 or 355
over 113 will never precisely equal pi
we'll never know what really happened to
HIPAA sious but what we do know is that
his discovery revolutionized mathematics
so whatever the myths may say don't be
afraid to explore the impossible
you
[Music]